our um motto is to be known to be loved
to be prepared because we feel like
those go together that is Catherine
Koontz one of the victims of Monday's
Massacre she was the head of the
Covenant School she was wholly devoted
to that Community Tricia Drake knew
Catherine Koontz professionally for
years after hearing about the shooting
Drake says she expected to see Koontz at
the center of the school's response I
just was telling my friends I'm sure
Catherine will come out and tell
everybody that everything's going to be
okay
and I I waited for that and I was just
stunned of all things to talk about
Drake said her last conversation with
coons was about active shooter training
and I know she would have done anything
to save those babies than her colleagues